now that said if the banks are over
leveraged what does that mean it means
the economy is over leveraged plain and
simple
we'd like to blame the banks but the
banks are just the financial industry is
just a pass-through of debt to the real
economy when when I talked about the 10%
increase in debt in the last two years
between twenty and twenty seventeen and
twenty nineteen that was households
businesses and government and just to be
clear that I'm not being political here
boy
the government debt has ballooned a lot
since 2008 it's been both political
parties there doesn't seem to be anybody
who is concerned about this both both
politically but it's not just the
government sector it's been the
corporate sector in the household sector
as well so the financial sector is
literally just a mirror of what's going
on in the real economy that the
households businesses and government
sectors and all three of those have been
pedals of the metal
and on borrowing really for the last 50
years this is just to be clear we I'm
talking a lot about 2008 but we've had
so many attempts by the free market to
assert itself
was 1968 we did have one year during the
financial crisis during which we saved
more than we borrowed but every other
year since then we've borrowed more than
we saved what does that mean it means
that we're consuming more than we
produced it's pretty simple and so if
you go back in history why did the u.s.
have why why did we become the strongest
economy in the world especially coming
off World War two and the answer is we
had the strongest balance sheet we were
an equity financed economy and what I
mean by that is if you looked at the
amount of money saved every year and the
amount of money borrowed every year it
was essentially equal year in year out
the borrowing that people did in the
United States was from every from
somebody else's savings within the
United States so we were what I would
call an equity finance economy we were
not borrowing against our future in
order to consume more today and we
started doing exactly that in 1968
that's when the guns and butter programs
so to speak were where we're taking
effect and so a lot of people point to
1971 as the problem I actually point to
1968 that's the year in which we started
really out living our means and every
year since then except for 2009 the
United States has outlived our means and
so how are we able to sustain it for 50
years I think a lot of people are saying
well gosh we don't have to care about
the debt this is a this something you'll
read in mainstream media we don't have
to care about the debt because we owe it
to ourselves or we can just print money
and therefore you know we can just push
pedal to the metal and keep printing
money and borrowing and to respond to
these crises with monetary and fiscal
policy respectively it used to be one or
now it's both and now neither one of
them seems to be working very well the
quantity of stimulus that we're having
to throw at this most recent crisis is
staggering because the size of the
bubble is that much more staggering
because we've had so much debt issued
that's non-productive in in especially
the last decade but even especially the
last two years and so what I would say
to those folks is you got lucky the ones
who think that that debt doesn't matter
you got lucky because for 50 years we
were able to do this in the United
States because our parents and
grandparents and their parents and
grandparents bequeathed us with an
unbelievable balance sheet we net debt
on our balance sheet up until 1968 in
the United States we were we were we
were all the borrowing that that people
did in the United States was was out of
somebody's savings and so that net debt
was zero for decades and then we started
going to town in 1968 and you know
unfortunately
if you look at the balance sheet of the
United States right now it's kind of an
ugly situation we have 83 points three
trillion of non financial sector debt
outstanding again that's the that's
households businesses and governments
together I would also add the Fed's
balance sheet is is should be added to
that as well so we're really north of 87
trillion of debt and I looked it up
last night the net wealth of the United
States is 104 trillion as of year-end
2019 so we've got right and that's
that's not fleeting the debt is
contractual that's that's somebody's
debt you know real obligation that's
real whereas some of the assets backing
that hundred four trillion dollar number
are not real they're fleeting right we
just saw 20 trillion come off the stock
market so if we've got eighty eighty
seven trillion of debt and 104 trillion
of net wealth to satisfy that and we
just took twenty trillion of value off
financial assets last week you do the
math this is why people I think are not
on are not irrational to be to be
nervous about the situation and start
questioning whether the things they've
been taught are really right